It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose Google Fi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month. Now that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore Google Fi Wireless plans today. Plus taxes and government fees.
现在是授粉高峰期，我的生意规模正在迅速扩大。为了保持花蜜源源不断，我需要一个拥有顶级优先数据速度的手机套餐。这就是我选择 Google Fi Wireless 的原因。即使在蜂巢最繁忙的时候，我的连接依然保持强劲。此外，无限流量套餐每月仅需 35 美元起。这可是一个不会一直有的优惠。立即探索 Google Fi Wireless 套餐。另需缴纳税费和政府费用。
Google Fi Wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. situation sound familiar. You grab a coffee or pick up a takeout order, tap your credit card to pay, and you're faced with a choice. The tablet suggests that you tip either 18, 20, or 25 percent. Do you accept the suggestion, or do you press no tip or maybe custom tip? With the barista and the person behind you in line watching, this decision feels loaded. Tipping has long been a part of service culture in the U.S., but in the last few years, the number of places. where we're asked for a tip by a person or even a machine has multiplied. Today we're going to talk to an expert in tipping about what drives our tipping behavior.
Google Fi Wireless 在网络使用高峰期不会受到数据流量降速的影响。这种情况你熟悉吗？你买了一杯咖啡或取了一份外卖，刷信用卡支付时，你面临一个选择。平板电脑建议你支付 18%、20% 或 25% 的小费。你是接受这个建议，还是点击“无小费”或“自定义小费”？在咖啡师和排在你后面的人的注视下，这个决定让人感到压力。在美国，小费长期以来一直是服务文化的一部分，但在过去几年里，我们被要求支付小费的地方——无论是通过人工还是机器——成倍增加了。今天，我们将与一位小费专家探讨是什么驱动了我们的给小费行为。
How much of tipping is about rewarding good service versus following a social norm or avoiding the feeling of being judged? How do biases affect who gets tipped more? Why do tipping norms vary so much from country to country? Is tipping a fair way to compensate people? And if not, what could be done to make things more equitable? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
给小费在多大程度上是为了奖励优质服务，而在多大程度上是为了遵循社会规范或避免被评判的感觉？偏见如何影响谁获得更多小费？为什么不同国家的小费规范差异如此之大？给小费是一种公平的补偿方式吗？如果不是，可以采取什么措施使事情变得更公平？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Michael Lynn, a professor of consumer behavior and marketing at the Peter and Stephanie Nolan School of Hotel Administration at Cornell University. He has studied tipping behavior for more than 30 years. His interest was first sparked when he paid his way through school by waiting tables and bartending. He's published more than 50 journal articles on tipping, and his work has been covered by dozens of mainstream media outlets, including the Wall Street Journal, The New York Times, NPR, the PBS News Hour, and CBS News. His new book published in February is called The Psychology of Tipping, Scientific Insights for Services, Customers, Workers, and Managers. Dr. Lynn, thank you for joining me today.
我是 Kim Mills。我今天的嘉宾是康奈尔大学彼得和斯蒂芬妮·诺兰酒店管理学院的消费者行为与营销学教授 Michael Lynn 博士。他研究小费行为已经超过 30 年了。他的兴趣最初是在他通过做服务员和调酒师来支付学费时被激发的。他发表了 50 多篇关于小费的学术论文，他的研究被数十家主流媒体报道，包括《华尔街日报》、《纽约时报》、NPR、PBS 新闻一小时和 CBS 新闻。他二月份出版的新书名为《小费心理学：为服务人员、顾客、工人和经理提供的科学见解》。Lynn 博士，感谢您今天加入我的节目。
Oh, thank you for inviting me. It's my pleasure to be here. Let's start with the big picture. Why do people tip and when you ask people what motivates them, what do they say? When you ask people, the overwhelming majority response is that people say they tip to reward good service. It turns out that's not as big a factor as people think. When I stand outside of restaurants and interview customers about their dining experience, for example, I find that the customer's own rating of service quality explains about 4% of the differences in tips left by different dining parties. That's bigger than you would expect by chance.
哦，谢谢您的邀请。很高兴能来到这里。让我们从大局谈起。人们为什么给小费？当你问人们是什么激励他们时，他们会说什么？当你问人们时，绝大多数人的回答是他们给小费是为了奖励优质服务。事实证明，这并不是人们想象中那么大的因素。例如，当我站在餐馆外采访顾客关于他们的用餐体验时，我发现顾客自己对服务质量的评价仅能解释不同用餐群体所给小费差异的约 4%。这比你偶然预期的要大。
There is a tendency to tip more for better service, but it's not the biggest driver of differences in tipping. What are the bigger motivations and drivers of tipping? It's really social expectations and the desire to live up to those social expectations to avoid disapproval, gain liking, etc. Why do I say that? Again, in interviews with customers outside of restaurants, what I find is that the biggest predictor of tipping is bill size, which isn't surprising. There's this 15 to 20 percent tipping norm in this country. What may be surprising to people is to learn that that explains about 70 percent of the differences in tips left by different dining parties, which means that there's only 30% left to be explained by everything else.
人们确实倾向于为更好的服务支付更多小费，但这并不是导致小费差异的最大驱动因素。那么，给小费的更大动机和驱动力是什么呢？其实是社会期望，以及为了避免不被认可、获得好感等而达到这些社会期望的愿望。我为什么这么说呢？同样，在餐馆外的顾客采访中，我发现给小费的最大预测指标是账单金额，这并不令人惊讶。在这个国家，存在 15% 到 20% 的小费规范。人们可能感到惊讶的是，这解释了不同用餐群体所给小费差异的约 70%，这意味着只有 30% 的差异是由其他因素解释的。
In other words, bill size is twice as powerful as everything else combined in driving tipping behavior. That social expectation is the biggest driver. The second biggest set of factors that influence tipping is the social rapport or connection between the service worker and the customer. And we believe that that works because obviously you care about the approval and living up to the expectations of people. that you have a connection with more than complete strangers or anonymous faces. Now, I heard a long time ago that the term tip is short for to ensure promptness, which I think is not true. But where did the term come from?
换句话说，账单金额在驱动小费行为方面的作用是其他所有因素总和的两倍。这种社会期望是最大的驱动力。影响小费的第二大因素是服务人员与顾客之间的社会融洽度或联系。我们认为这是有效的，因为显然，你更关心与你有联系的人的认可和期望，而不是完全的陌生人或匿名面孔。现在，我很久以前听说“tip”（小费）这个词是“to ensure promptness”（确保及时）的缩写，我认为这不是真的。但这个词是从哪里来的呢？
So there's a lot to that. First, you're absolutely right. Tipping does not stand for to ensure promptness, even though there's plenty of people arguing that it does. But the fact is that acronyms didn't really become popular until the 19th century, and the term tipping has been around longer than that. There are lots of different explanations. There is the word tip in thieves can't is give me, and so people have argued that it derives from this kind of criminal language that people have argued that it comes from the word tipple, as in drinking. The argument here is that tipping evolved in eating and drinking establishments as a way, of forestalling service providers envy. After all, you're enjoying yourself, having a social time, eating, drinking, and they're laboring to serve you would be natural for them to be a little
关于这一点有很多说法。首先，你是完全正确的。小费并不代表“确保及时”，尽管有很多人争论说它是。但事实是，缩写词直到 19 世纪才真正流行起来，而“tipping”这个词存在的时间比那更长。有很多不同的解释。在盗贼黑话（thieves' cant）中有一个词“tip”，意思是“给我”，所以人们争论说它源于这种犯罪语言；也有人争论说它来自“tipple”这个词，即喝酒。这里的论点是，小费在餐饮场所演变出来，作为一种预先防止服务提供者产生嫉妒的方式。毕竟，你在享受时光，进行社交，吃喝玩乐，而他们却在辛苦地为你服务，他们感到一点嫉妒是很自然的。
envious and who knows what they might do. So Tipping evolved is a way of saying, hey, don't envy me. Here's some money. You can have a drink on me later. This is the theory of an anthropologist named George Foster. And consistent with that explanation, the word for TIP in many different different languages, translates to drink money, money for drink. So that's certainly a theory about where tipping came from. But there's not a whole lot of good research, historical research, on the origins of tipping worldwide. How much is tipping driven by social approval? I mean, do people want to be seen as the person who leaves a good tip? Oh, absolutely. I think that's the major driver of tipping for the reasons that we've already mentioned, right? The biggest
嫉妒，谁知道他们会做什么呢？所以小费演变成了一种方式，意思是：“嘿，别嫉妒我。给你些钱，你以后可以喝杯酒。”这是人类学家 George Foster 的理论。与这种解释一致的是，在许多不同的语言中，“小费”一词翻译过来就是“酒钱”。所以这当然是关于小费起源的一种理论。但是，关于全球小费起源的好的历史研究并不多。给小费在多大程度上是由社会认可驱动的？我的意思是，人们是否想被视为给小费大方的人？哦，绝对是。我认为这是给小费的主要驱动力，原因是我们已经提到的，对吧？最大的
determinant of tipping is the social norm, the social expectation. And the second biggest set of factors are the degree to which you care about the approval and liking of that service provider. Lots of little things that service providers can do to make themselves more likable, to make you care about their opinion more, have a pretty substantial impact on tipping. Well, we'll get to those in a minute, but I want to ask in your new book about tipping, you talk about time of day as influencing tipping. How does that work and why? I can tell you what the effect is, and that is that people leave larger tip percentages early in the morning at breakfast and late in the evening and moderate tip percentages at lunch and dinner. Why is a totally open question. I am not sure. Well, you also found that, tipping rates vary by geography. So tell us about that. What are the differences? Urban areas tend to tip more than rural areas in this country. There are state differences in tipping. The biggest predictor of those state differences is how servers are paid. In the United States,
决定小费的因素是社会规范，即社会期望。第二大因素是你对服务提供者的认可和好感的关心程度。服务提供者可以做很多小事来让自己更讨人喜欢，让你更关心他们的评价，这对小费有相当大的影响。好吧，我们稍后再谈这些，但我想问一下，在你的新书里，你谈到了时间段会影响小费。这是怎么运作的，为什么？我可以告诉你效果是什么，那就是人们在清晨早餐时和深夜时给的小费百分比更高，而在午餐和晚餐时给的小费百分比适中。为什么会这样是一个完全开放的问题。我不确定。好吧，你还发现小费率因地理位置而异。那么告诉我们关于这一点。有什么区别？在这个国家，城市地区往往比农村地区给的小费更多。各州之间的小费也存在差异。这些州差异的最大预测指标是服务员的薪酬方式。在美国，
it is not uncommon for servers to get less than the standard minimum wage, but how much less varies from one state to the next. The states where servers are paid the smallest amount are the states where people tip higher percentages. That's the major driver of differences in tipping, although I've done some research showing, for example, that in coffee shop, states where people score higher on kindness tend to tip more. Let's talk for a minute about tip creep. In the last few years, those digital payment screens are popping up everywhere, even at self-service kiosks. Have they changed the norms around tipping and are we now expected to tip in situations where we weren't in the past? Yes, we are expected to tip in situations where we weren't
服务员拿到的工资低于标准最低工资并不罕见，但具体低多少因州而异。服务员薪酬最低的州，往往是人们给小费百分比最高的州。这是导致小费差异的主要驱动因素，尽管我做过一些研究表明，例如，在咖啡店，人们在友善度得分较高的州往往会给更多小费。让我们谈谈“小费蔓延”（tip creep）。在过去几年里，那些数字支付屏幕随处可见，甚至在自助服务亭也是如此。它们改变了关于小费的规范吗？我们现在是否被期望在过去不需要给小费的情况下给小费？是的，我们被期望在过去不需要给小费的情况下给小费，
in the past, but you need to ask yourself who has that expectation and does it really matter? I get asked all the time, how much should I tip? And I don't want to tell people that because I'm not an authority. What basis do I have to tell you what you should do? And guess what? Emily Post, Amy Vanderbilt, etiquette experts don't really have that authority either. There is no god of tipping. Tipping norms don't come from on high. They evolve from the behavior of consumers and they become so common and so prevalent that we tend to judge people who don't follow that descriptive norm. And that's how we get the injunctive norm of tipping. What's important for people to realize is when people ask for tips, they want the tip and they expect you to give it to them.
但你需要问自己，谁有这种期望？这真的重要吗？我经常被问到：“我应该给多少小费？”我不想告诉人们，因为我不是权威。我有什么依据告诉你你应该做什么？你猜怎么着？Emily Post、Amy Vanderbilt 等礼仪专家其实也没有那种权威。没有所谓的“小费之神”。小费规范不是从天而降的。它们是从消费者的行为中演变出来的，变得如此普遍，以至于我们倾向于评判那些不遵循这种描述性规范的人。这就是我们如何得到小费的指令性规范。人们需要意识到的是，当人们要求小费时，他们想要小费，并且期望你给他们。
And they're going to be unhappy with you if you don't. On the other hand, in many of these circumstances, most people are not tipping. For example, restaurant carry out today if you order food from a restaurant, go pick it up and bring it home. Almost all of those places are going to ask you for a tip. Only 22% of customers say they usually tip in that circumstance. Is it really a norm if only 22% of people are doing it? it's something to keep in mind. If you say no tip,
如果你不给，他们会不高兴。另一方面，在许多这些情况下，大多数人并没有给小费。例如，今天的餐馆外卖，如果你从餐馆订餐，去取餐并带回家，几乎所有这些地方都会向你索要小费。只有 22% 的顾客表示他们通常在这种情况下给小费。如果只有 22% 的人这样做，这真的算是一种规范吗？这是需要记住的一点。如果你说不给小费，
that service provider's going to be unhappy with you, but you're not the only person they're going to be unhappy with. 70% of their other customers are also going to be subject to that disapproval and that diffuses the impact bit. At least for me, it does. Why do you think that seeing a screen prompt
那个服务提供者会不高兴，但你不是他们唯一会不高兴的对象。他们 70% 的其他顾客也会受到这种不赞同的影响，这在一定程度上分散了影响。至少对我来说是这样。你认为为什么看到屏幕提示
feels different from seeing a tip jar on the counter? Does the screen actually help us determine how much to tip, or was it created to just push us to leave more? First off, the screen does typically contain one-touch options, which come across as defining social expectations and norms, whereas the tip dart doesn't have that. By the way, research shows that the more you ask for, the more you get.
感觉与看到柜台上的小费罐不同？屏幕真的能帮助我们确定给多少小费吗，还是它被创造出来只是为了促使我们多给？首先，屏幕通常包含一键式选项，这给人一种定义社会期望和规范的感觉，而小费罐则没有。顺便说一句，研究表明，你要求的越多，你得到的就越多。
The larger the options, the more likely people are to opt out and say, I'm not going to tip at all, but the tips from those who do decide to tip are, are larger and the net effect on income is to increase income. And that's one of the reasons you see this escalation in the amounts people are asking for because it increases tip income. But it's not just those one touch options that are different. In a tip jar, if I don't tip, I simply refrain from putting money into the tip jar. It is a sin of omission. To leave no tip and these digital devices, I have to actively hit a button that says no tip. That's a sin of commission.
选项越大，人们越有可能选择退出，说“我根本不给小费”，但那些决定给小费的人给的金额更大，对收入的净影响是增加收入。这就是为什么你会看到人们要求的小费金额不断升级的原因之一，因为它增加了小费收入。但不仅仅是那些一键式选项不同。在小费罐里，如果我不给小费，我只是不往罐子里放钱。这是一种“不作为的罪”。而不给小费，在这些数字设备上，我必须主动点击一个写着“无小费”的按钮。这是一种“作为的罪”。
And we tend to judge people more for things they do than for things they don't do. So these digital devices increase social pressure. They also increase social pressure because they hide information that's available with the tip jar. In a tip jar, first off, it's pretty evident when someone puts money in. So if I'm standing in line, I can see how many people before me have put money in. And in addition, the tip jar is typically, you can see into it and you can see how much money there is. In counter service and other circumstances, most people don't tip and the tip jar is not likely to be full unless the staff salted it. And even in that case, you can tell that you didn't see other people put money in.
我们倾向于因为人们做的事情而不是不做的事情来评判他们。所以这些数字设备增加了社会压力。它们还增加了社会压力，因为它们隐藏了小费罐所具备的信息。在小费罐里，首先，当有人放钱时是很明显的。所以如果我排在队里，我可以看到我前面有多少人放了钱。此外，小费罐通常是可以看进去的，你可以看到里面有多少钱。在柜台服务和其他情况下，大多数人并不给小费，而且除非员工往里面放了“底钱”，否则小费罐不太可能装满。即使在这种情况下，你也能看出你没有看到其他人放钱。
These digital screens hide that information. You don't know how much other people have tipped. And yes, I'm standing in line behind someone, but their back is blocking the screen. and pulling money out and putting it into a jar is much more visible than hitting a button on a screen. And so I think the fact that we don't have information about what other people are doing, combined with the fact that everybody's asking, leads people to assume if they're asking it must be the new norm. And I'm here to tell you that's not true. Do you have any theories to why Americans tip more than most other people of other nationalities?
这些数字屏幕隐藏了这些信息。你不知道其他人给了多少小费。是的，我排在某人后面，但他们的背挡住了屏幕。而且从口袋里掏钱放进罐子里比在屏幕上按一个按钮要显眼得多。所以我认为，我们没有关于其他人正在做什么的信息，加上每个人都在索要小费，导致人们认为如果他们索要，那一定是新的规范。但我在这里告诉你，那不是真的。你对为什么美国人比大多数其他国籍的人给更多小费有什么理论吗？
I can speculate. I have done research on national differences in tipping, and those differences reflect in part differences in the values and the personality traits of the national populations. So, for example, tipping is more common and people tip larger amounts, the more extroverted the people in a country are. And the United States is a part of those studies and is consistent with that. So we tip more people in larger amounts than other countries, and we tend to be a above average in extroversion. But we're not extreme on extroversion, and we are very extreme
我可以推测。我做过关于小费国家差异的研究，这些差异在一定程度上反映了国民价值观和人格特质的差异。例如，一个国家的人民越外向，给小费就越普遍，给的金额也越大。美国是这些研究的一部分，结果与此一致。所以我们比其他国家给更多的人更多的小费，而且我们在外向性方面往往高于平均水平。但我们在外向性方面并不极端，而我们在小费行为上却非常极端。
in our tipping behavior. And so because we're this outlier, a single case, it makes it hard to have any definitive answer to why are we so unique. But we can speculate. And my guess is that it has to do with labor laws. And we're the only country I know of where waiters and waitresses are allowed to be paid less than the standard minimum wage. And most consumers in this country are aware of that. And that puts pressure on them to try to make up for those low wages and contribute, certainly to the amounts we're willing to tip waiters and waitresses. Why we tip a greater range of service providers I don't have as compelling an explanation for. What are some of the other countries where people tip a little?
因为我们是这个离群值，一个单一的案例，这使得很难对我们为什么如此独特给出明确的答案。但我们可以推测。我的猜测是这与劳动法有关。据我所知，我们是唯一一个允许服务员拿低于标准最低工资的工资的国家。这个国家的绝大多数消费者都知道这一点。这给他们带来了压力，试图弥补这些低工资，并确实促成了我们愿意给服务员的小费金额。为什么我们给更多种类的服务提供者小费，我没有那么令人信服的解释。还有哪些国家的人给小费较少？
Japan, Iceland, Denmark, those are countries where tipping is pretty rare. You know, I want to say, of course, Canada, Mexico, parts of the Americas, they don't tip as much as us, but more than elsewhere. We're going to take a short break. When we return, I'll talk with Dr. Lynn about bias and tipping, who gets tipped more and who gets tipped less, and whether there are ways to make tipping more equitable. Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill,
日本、冰岛、丹麦，这些国家的小费相当少。你知道，我想说，当然，加拿大、墨西哥、美洲部分地区，他们给的小费不如我们多，但比其他地方多。我们要休息一下。回来后，我将与 Lynn 博士讨论小费中的偏见、谁获得更多小费、谁获得较少小费，以及是否有方法使小费更公平。你的夏天从家得宝（The Home Depot）的阵亡将士纪念日促销开始。是时候用 Next Grill 开启夏季烧烤了，
four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price in valid May 14th or May 27th. U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price map. That's for details.
四头燃气烤架，特价仅需 199 美元。整个季节都可以用 Hampton Bay West Grove 七件套户外餐桌椅套装来招待客人，仅需 49 美元。这个阵亡将士纪念日，在家得宝享受低价保证。售完即止，价格有效期为 5 月 14 日至 5 月 27 日。仅限美国，适用排除条款。详情请参阅 HomeDepot.com/pricematch。
You said this place was steps from the water. We just haven't found the steps yet. How much did we save? Enough. Enough to get lost. Or you could book a stay with Hilton. Welcome to your ocean front room. Just steps from the water.
你说这个地方离水边只有几步之遥。我们只是还没找到那几步路。我们省了多少钱？够了。足够去迷失自我了。或者你可以预订希尔顿酒店的住宿。欢迎来到你的海滨房间。距离水边仅几步之遥。
The Hilton sale is on now. Book on Hilton.com or the Hilton app and save up to 20% to get the stay you expected. When you want savings, not surprises. It matters where you stay. Hilton for this day. Your research has looked at bias in tipping as well. Are there patterns of discrimination that show up in terms of who gets more, who gets
希尔顿促销活动现已开启。在 Hilton.com 或希尔顿应用程序上预订，最高可享 8 折优惠，获得你期待的住宿体验。当你想要节省开支，而不是意外时，你住哪里很重要。希尔顿，为了这次住宿。你的研究也关注了小费中的偏见。在谁获得更多、谁获得
tip less, and why? So first off, waiters tend to get more in tips than waitresses, but that is almost certainly because of where they work and the times that they work. They're more likely to work at upscale restaurants and to work evening shifts. waitresses are more likely to work at less fancy restaurants and to work breakfast, lunch shifts, and that contributes to differences in tip income. Controlling for where people work, nowadays we don't get huge differences in tips between waiters and waitresses. There is research showing that waitresses who are physically attractive get better tips than those who are less attractive.
更少小费方面，是否存在歧视模式？为什么？首先，男服务员往往比女服务员获得更多小费，但这几乎肯定是因为他们工作的地方和工作的时间。他们更有可能在高档餐厅工作，并上晚班。女服务员更有可能在不太高档的餐厅工作，并上早餐和午餐班，这导致了小费收入的差异。在控制了工作地点后，如今男服务员和女服务员之间的小费差异并不大。有研究表明，外貌出众的女服务员比外貌较差的女服务员获得更好的小费。
And then we can look at race. There's pretty good data that black servers in this country get lower tips than white servers. And what's really interesting is that that's true even if the customer is black. Now, given that inherent bias, do you think we'd be better off just doing away with tipping? I mean, or are there ways to keep tipping but make it more fair? Yeah, that's a good question. And frankly, I've done other interviews. like this, so I'm on record being on both sides of that issue, in part because my opinion
然后我们可以看看种族。有相当好的数据表明，这个国家的黑人服务员获得的小费比白人服务员少。真正有趣的是，即使顾客是黑人，情况也是如此。现在，考虑到这种内在的偏见，你认为我们最好取消小费吗？我的意思是，或者有没有办法保留小费但使其更公平？是的，这是一个好问题。坦率地说，我做过其他类似的采访，所以我记录在案，在这两个立场上都有过观点，部分原因是我随着做更多的研究和学习更多，我的观点
changes as I do more research and learn more. I used to think, yeah, because of these inherent biases, we'd be better off getting rid of tipping. But it turns out that lots of restaurants have tried this and their online ratings go down. Customer satisfaction is improved by tipping. And since there are way more customers than servers, I'm a little loathe to get rid of this benefit to consumers to protect a few servers, right? There's got to be a better way. What is that better way? I'm not 100% sure. Perhaps we could allow tip pooling and sharing of tips more equitably among the wait staff. Currently, you can do that if you don't take the tip credit. If you pay the standard minimum wage by federal law, you can require your servers to pool their
发生了变化。我曾经认为，是的，因为这些内在的偏见，我们最好取消小费。但事实证明，很多餐馆尝试过这样做，他们的在线评分下降了。小费提高了顾客满意度。由于顾客比服务员多得多，我有点不愿为了保护少数服务员而取消这种对消费者的好处，对吧？一定有更好的方法。那更好的方法是什么？我不是 100% 确定。也许我们可以允许小费池化，并在服务员之间更公平地分享小费。目前，如果你不采取“小费抵扣”（tip credit），你可以这样做。如果你按照联邦法律支付标准最低工资，你可以要求你的服务员汇集他们的
tips and then you can distribute them in an equitable way. But if you take the tip credit, which most people do, you're not allowed to have that kind of tip pooling. Certainly one option would be to liberalize the laws and allow for more tip pooling. But there's a downside of that too. Consumers don't like the idea of forcing servers to share tips. If I give a waiter money, I want that waiter to have the money, not to put it in a pool where people that didn't wait on me receive a share. So do I have a magic wand, a magic answer? No. I'm sorry, I wish I did. I can only tell you what the issues are and how people view them.
小费，然后你可以以公平的方式分配它们。但如果你采取了小费抵扣，大多数人都会这样做，你就不能进行那种小费池化。当然，一个选择是放宽法律，允许更多的小费池化。但这样做也有缺点。消费者不喜欢强迫服务员分享小费的想法。如果我给服务员钱，我希望那个服务员得到钱，而不是把它放进一个池子里，让那些没有为我服务的人分一杯羹。所以我有一根魔杖，一个神奇的答案吗？没有。对不起，我希望我有。我只能告诉你问题是什么，以及人们是如何看待它们的。
How would consumers know that tips are being pooled? I mean, I worked in one restaurant where tips were pooled. And I also wonder whether the servers felt it was unfair. You know, I worked harder. I'm a better server and I'm getting as much as, you know, the person at the next table. servers don't like the idea of tip pooling. They would prefer to keep their own tips. How would customers know? Obviously, only if someone told them. But it's hard to imagine that that wouldn't get out at some point. Another question, and I'm harking back to my day's waiting tables, because I did in a number of places when I was young and in college like you.
消费者怎么知道小费被池化了？我的意思是，我在一家餐馆工作过，那里的小费是池化的。我也想知道服务员是否觉得这不公平。你知道，我工作更努力。我是个更好的服务员，但我得到的和小费罐旁边的人一样多。服务员不喜欢小费池化的想法。他们更愿意保留自己的小费。顾客怎么会知道？显然，只有当有人告诉他们时。但很难想象这在某个时候不会传出去。另一个问题，我回想起我做服务员的日子，因为我年轻时在大学里像你一样在很多地方做过。
So when I was a waitress many years ago, I had one colleague who routinely told customers that it was her birthday, pretty much every day. And that got her better tips. So what are some of the things that service providers should do to get better tips short of lying? Anything that increases social rapport and connection. Big open-mouthed smiles have been shown to increase tips. Touching customers briefly on the arm or shoulder at some point during the dining experience increases tips, standing closer to the table, say a half a foot as opposed to a foot and a half away, has been shown to increase tips. Squatting down, not every time you interact,
所以当我多年前做服务员时，我有一个同事每天都习惯性地告诉顾客今天是她的生日，几乎每天都这样。这让她获得了更好的小费。那么，除了撒谎之外，服务提供者应该做些什么来获得更好的小费呢？任何增加社会融洽度和联系的事情。大张嘴的微笑已被证明可以增加小费。在用餐体验期间的某个时刻短暂触摸顾客的手臂或肩膀会增加小费，站得离桌子更近，比如半英尺而不是一英尺半，已被证明可以增加小费。蹲下来，不是每次互动都这样，
but at least on some of the occasions when you interact with the table, especially when you're just coming to introduce yourself, describe what's specials of the day, etc. If you squat down next to the table, it brings your eye level down to the same eye level of this customer facilitates eye contact, also makes you appear to be physically closer, and it's been shown to increase tips. And one study, a waiter got a dollar more per table if he squatted down than if he remained standing all the time. Writing thank you on the back of the check. And if you write thank you and you have the customer's name because, for example, they gave a credit card instead of just saying thank you, say thank you, Mr. Smith, that increases
但至少在你与餐桌互动的某些场合，特别是当你刚来介绍自己、描述当日特色菜等时。如果你蹲在桌子旁边，它会把你的视线降低到与顾客相同的视线水平，促进眼神交流，也让你看起来在物理上更亲近，这已被证明可以增加小费。在一项研究中，如果服务员蹲下来，他每张桌子比一直站着多获得一美元。在账单背面写上“谢谢”。如果你写上“谢谢”，并且你有顾客的名字，例如，他们给了信用卡，而不是只说“谢谢”，说“谢谢，Smith 先生”，这会增加
is. Has your research influenced your own tipping behavior? I mean, do you think about research when you're eating out and the check comes? Yes, and it's influenced it in a couple of ways. First off, because I do a lot of interviews like this and people ask me about tipping, my own tipping habits, that puts pressure on me to be able to truthfully say I'm a good tipper. And so I routinely give 18% in restaurants because I don't, I don't. I don't want to seem like I'm extravagant, but I don't want to be cheap. But having said that, my awareness of actual tipping behavior in many of these new context in that people are asking for tips, but consumers aren't giving them in many of these
小费。你的研究影响了你自己的小费行为吗？我的意思是，当你在外面吃饭结账时，你会想到研究吗？是的，它在几个方面影响了我。首先，因为我做了很多这样的采访，人们问我关于小费的问题，我自己的小费习惯，这给我带来了压力，让我能够真实地说我是一个给小费大方的人。所以我通常在餐馆给 18% 的小费，因为我不想看起来很奢侈，但我也不想显得吝啬。但话虽如此，我对许多这些新背景下实际小费行为的认识，即人们在索要小费，但消费者在许多这些
counter service kinds of situations, that absolutely frees me up to join those people who say, no, I'm not going to tip in that circumstance. And I do. I refuse to tip for counter service unless I ask for some special treatment that's provided at some effort, then I'll leave a tip. But otherwise no, and I do think it's awareness through my research of what other people are doing that lets me say no. Have we maxed out? I mean, are we at the point where 20% is the ceiling or is it going to keep going up to you think? There's not a lot of systematic research, but I did do a study looking at academic research. search on restaurant tipping, and we looked at actual tips left in real restaurants, not just
柜台服务类的情况下并没有给小费，这绝对让我可以自由地加入那些说“不，在这种情况下我不会给小费”的人的行列。我确实这样做。我拒绝为柜台服务给小费，除非我要求了一些需要付出努力的特殊服务，那么我会留下小费。但除此之外，不给。我确实认为，通过我的研究了解其他人正在做什么，让我可以说“不”。我们达到极限了吗？我的意思是，我们是否到了 20% 是上限的地步，还是你认为它会继续上升？没有多少系统的研究，但我确实做了一项研究，查看了关于餐馆小费的学术研究。我们查看了真实餐馆中留下的实际小费，而不仅仅是
self-reports of general tendencies. And tips have increased over the last 50 years. That increase was linear. It didn't start off big increases that slowly got smaller. No, it's a straight linear effect, which suggests that they're going to continue to go up. There's no indication. Having said that, there's got to be a ceiling somewhere. The question is where? And I don't know if any basis for making that prediction. I'm sorry. Let me just wrap up by asking you what you're working on now. I mean, you just finished, you know, but published a book and I'm sure that took a lot of time and effort. But what are the areas where you continue to do research? Right now I have two projects going on. One with a high school student named Arjun Agarwal. He developed an app that allows people to scan a QR code and leave a tip. And he's testing this with the shuttle drivers to, the Austin Airport in Austin, Texas. He contacted me wanting to do some research. So I'm guiding him through this project where he's got different conditions, one where there's just a custom tip and no one-touch options, one-touch options where they're ascending, five, ten, 15, and the other
关于一般倾向的自我报告。过去 50 年来，小费一直在增加。这种增长是线性的。它不是从大的增长开始，然后慢慢变小。不，这是一个直线线性效应，这表明它们将继续上升。没有迹象表明会停止。话虽如此，某个地方一定有一个上限。问题是上限在哪里？我不知道有什么依据可以做出这种预测。对不起。让我最后问一下你现在在做什么。我的意思是，你刚刚完成并出版了一本书，我相信这花了很多时间和精力。但你还在哪些领域继续进行研究？现在我有两个项目正在进行。一个与名叫 Arjun Agarwal 的高中生合作。他开发了一个应用程序，允许人们扫描二维码并留下小费。他正在奥斯汀机场的班车司机身上测试这个，在德克萨斯州奥斯汀。他联系我想要做一些研究。所以我正在指导他完成这个项目，他有不同的条件，一种是只有自定义小费，没有一键式选项；一种是一键式选项，它们是升序的，5、10、15；另一种
third condition where there are one-touch options and descending. And we want to see which of those impacts tipping and how they impact customers' ratings of the service as well. The only other study that I'm actively involved in is with a colleague named Mike McCaw, where we're looking at some additional predictors of national differences in tipping. Well, Dr. Lynn, I want to thank you for joining me. I think you've given us a lot of interesting information that may well influence how our listeners tip in the future, but I hope that we're not going to stiff anybody who doesn't deserve to be stiffed. By the way, I'm not encouraging people to stiff servers. I'm saying you get to make that decision yourself, right? And don't feel pressured. Don't tip out of a sense of obligation. But if you
第三种条件是有一键式选项且是降序的。我们想看看哪种条件会影响小费，以及它们如何影响顾客对服务的评价。我积极参与的唯一另一项研究是与一位名叫 Mike McCaw 的同事合作，我们正在研究小费国家差异的一些额外预测指标。好吧，Lynn 博士，我要感谢您的加入。我认为您给了我们很多有趣的信息，这些信息很可能会影响我们听众未来给小费的方式，但我希望我们不会冷落任何不该被冷落的人。顺便说一句，我不是在鼓励人们冷落服务员。我是说你可以自己做那个决定，对吧？不要感到压力。不要出于义务感给小费。但如果你
like this person, you want to help them out, or if they did a really fantastic job and you want to reward them and say, thank you, by all means do so. Good advice. Thank you. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, please follow us and leave a rating. If you have comments or ideas for future episodes, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Thank you for listening for the American Psychological Association. I'm Kim Mills. Enjoy more ways to save at Ralph's, like low prices in every aisle.
喜欢这个人，你想帮助他们，或者如果他们做得非常出色，你想奖励他们并说“谢谢”，那么一定要这样做。很好的建议。谢谢。你可以在我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org 或 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你所听到的，请关注我们并留下评分。如果你对未来的节目有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。《心理学谈话》由 Lee Wynerman 制作。感谢收听美国心理学会的节目。我是 Kim Mills。在 Ralph's 享受更多省钱方式，比如每个过道的低价。
And when you download the Ralph's app, you can clip and save more with digital coupons every week. Plus, you can earn fuel points to save up to $1 per gallon at the pump. At Ralph's, you can enjoy more ways to save and more rewards every time you shop. So it's always easy to save big every day with savings and rewards. Ralph's SoCal for over 150 years. Savings may vary by state. Fuel restrictions apply. Seasite for details. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当你下载 Ralph's 应用程序时，你可以每周通过数字优惠券剪辑并节省更多。此外，你可以赚取燃油积分，在加油站每加仑节省高达 1 美元。在 Ralph's，你每次购物都可以享受更多省钱方式和更多奖励。所以，通过储蓄和奖励，每天都能轻松省大钱。Ralph's SoCal 超过 150 年。储蓄可能因州而异。适用燃油限制。详情请参阅网站。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。